Speaker 1: Making big news over the weekend
is a short video clip in which Jared Kushner,
Donald Trump's son in law. Attacks or criticizes
may be better, said Ron DeSantis is Martha's
Vineyard immigrant. Now, as a reminder,
this is the stunt in which Ron DeSantis
sent via plane migrants awaiting asylum
adjudication in Texas to Martha's Vineyard,
a small island off the coast of Massachusetts.
Lied to them, promised jobs, said you're going
to Boston, you're going to get expedited, regular
normalization of your immigration, said. All these
different lies lured them there, potentially
illegal, using these people's lives essentially
as political pawns. So a big deal was made of
the fact that Jared Kushner went on Fox News
and he said he was against it. He said
he doesn't like what Ron DeSantis did.
There is a very specific, self-serving reason why
he said this, and many of you already know what it
is. Let's look at the clip and then discuss.
Speaker 2: I also we have to remember,
these are human beings. They're people. So
seeing them being used as political pawns one
way or the other is is very troubling to me.
Speaker 1: Okay. Jared's against it. He says
these are people seeing these people use the
people as political pawns is troubling to me.
Wow. That's that's true. I agree with that. Right.
Well, let's just think of both the hypocrisy and
the real reason for this. Number one, the
hypocrisy is that during Trump's presidency,
he tried to do something very similar. He
said if there's an interview where Myles
Taylor spoke about this, Trump said,
let's bus immigrants from the border
and put them in Democratic cities. And Trump
actually wanted to. Trump's idea was, let's find
the ones that are that are criminals and bring
them to democratic cities. So Trump wanted to
do the exact same thing. There is no moral high
ground here for what Jared Kushner is saying.
The reason why Jared Kushner is
saying this is very, very simple.
In the betting markets. Ron DeSantis has now
taken a lead over Donald Trump in terms of who is
expected to be the Republican presidential nominee
in 2024. We have seen this fight growing now for
months and months. Donald Trump increasingly
was furious with Ron DeSantis because when Ron
DeSantis was asked about running in 2024, DeSantis
didn't say, Well, I would only consider running if
Trump doesn't want it. Trump is mad at DeSantis
because Trump wants to sand this on his knees,
praying at the altar of Trump and saying, If the
orange, fearless leader wants the nomination,
I will get out of the way. DeSantis hasn't done
that, and that has caused anger for Donald Trump.
And slowly but surely over the last year we have
seen in the betting numbers, remember, this is
when people bet on who they believe will be the
nominee, not polling. The betting numbers have
shifted more and more and more away from being in
Trump's favor to the point where now Ron DeSantis,
by a small margin, is favored to be the Republican
2024 nominee in the betting markets. This is why
Jared Kushner is taking the opportunity to attack
the Sanders. It's not because of an actual moral
conflict here where he doesn't like what it
is that Ron DeSantis did because Trump tried
to do the exact same thing. That's what this is
about. And my hope is that it gets very, very ugly
between Trump and DeSantis. My hope is that Trump
wants the nomination and that so does the Santos,
and that they get into a big to do and it just
sabotages them. That would really be the goal.